so guys i just got home
i just got home from essex it's three in
the morning
i've got news that
shooting has happened in new zealand
about 30 muslims
shot children killed
i'm watching the video right now of this
scumbag who's
live streaming doing this
just watching this i'm not there
and knowing what this filthy scumbag did
just like his scumbag friends
isis both maniacs
both killing innocent people
i'm watching this right now i can't show
you it
he's opening his boot look he's taking
out
the machine guns look he's got machine
guns
with writings on them
and wallahi my heart is beaten
my heart is beating i don't know what
those people are going through
i can imagine the same thing that
happened in london bridge attacks
manchester attacks these innocent people
look at this guy he's walking
to the mosque
it's unbelievable look he's walking to
the mosque
foreign
oh
he shot everyone he shot everyone in the
masjid
please don't watch this disturbing
what lies disturbing
he's just killing his own people
he's just killed innocent people
he's just kill innocent people
he's scumbags
he's just shot innocent people
he's just killed innocent people
what did they do to them same as these
isis scumbags they kill innocent people
what have these people done to you
what have they done to you
this is what happens hate hate breathes
hate
he's just killed innocent people he just
shot a woman in the head
innocent people london bridge in
manchester
in iraq now in new zealand
it is a people going about their life
they're dead
he's killed at these 30 flipping people
i cannot believe it one night i cannot
believe this
is really happening
i just watched the video
of this filthy scumbag
this piece of [ __ ] this dirt
bag this flipping filthy scumbag
just like his scumbag isis friends
these flipping extremist filthy dogs
i just watched the video of him
shooting 30 to 40 people dead
point blank going back there reloading
shooting every single one of them in the
head
and what
seeing anyone die is wrong
but women and children he goes outside
and he sees one sister one sister
out there and he shoots her this filthy
scumbag
these dirtbags who killed innocent
people in manchester
in london bridge attacks and this filthy
scumbag these are the same
filthy dirtbags these scumbags who
kill innocent muslims innocent
non-muslims and
they feed off each other hate breathes
hate that's why we are so staunch
and so so against
isis supporters the far right these
filthy dogs these scumbags
i'll say it's straight up click i don't
care what anybody says
andrew chowdhury tommy robinson britain
first these
filthy dirtbags these scumbags are the
reason why
these people
he went he shot this he shot the sister
she's on the floor screaming he goes
there and shoots two bullets to her head
i will never ever forget that with the
rest of my life
never forget that and the same goes
for these isis filthy scums of the earth
who killed innocent people in manchester
do you see why we flipping and some
people have a go at me
why are you confronting these uh
brothers in the park
why are you confronting the far right
yeah this is the reason why
this is the flipping reason why because
these
scums these dirt bags
are the reason why innocent non-muslims
and innocent muslims
are suffering at their hand filthy
dirt scum of the earth tommy robinson
britain first
and his likes and angel charges and
these isis dirtbags
are the reason why innocent people are
suffering
and you have a go at us you have a goal
as for confronting these guys
and being harsh with
i'm a them i'm disturbed i'm disturbed
after what i saw
i'm disturbed i'm disturbed
he's casually shooting people and going
in the sky and listening to music
he run any muslim that's watching this
yeah you youngsters yeah
do not let this dirt scumbag
make you feel like you need to go
and avenge this in some way okay don't
don't ever think to yourself because
this is what this dirtbag
scumbag wants just like tommy robinson
he wants a civil war
he wants a war between us and the
non-muslims
that's not going to happen that is not
going to happen
yeah don't let isis
make you judge a whole nation a whole
people of islam
never let dirtbags like this make you
judge
the general non-muslims yeah don't fall
for this
do not fall for this do not let them
cause us to fight one another it's not
going to happen
deal with this gun